[musique]
nous travaillons dans des conditions telles que
valorisons notre santé
ainsi que l'humidité ainsi que l'humidité ainsi que
nous vivons dans des pirogues
l'arrière de la jambe a également besoin d'être réhabilité
chargement
Encore une fois, les garçons sont venus à l'unité
rééducation et vous pouvez voir que les gars
ils arrivent dans une semaine et reviennent à
leurs unités sont déjà un peu reposées
gagner une nouvelle force
cette mesure, il aide
à un militaire, au moins temporairement
semaine pour vous mettre en ordre au moins
dormir dans un lit chaud, c'est tout
premier lavage dans des conditions normales
choisir ses vêtements est la deuxième chose à faire
l'examen médical est la raison la plus importante
qu'une personne a pendant de telles batailles
stress
diverses maladies apparaissent
[musique]